so much like random ass news got dropped
over the past two days the latest thing
to talk about is for lat for the
expansions but there's to have comment
and basically outline the next three
months worth of DLC that they've decided
to put at like there was a bunch for
fallout three broken steel the pace
point look edge that mothership zeta
thing and right now they've announced
three different packs they're coming out
march april may the first one march
coming in sometime we march at Omicron
ten dollars apparently this hordes of
robots everywhere you go and kill them
and there's this big one called robo
brain which you have to kill and then
you can basically construct your own
sort of robot out of parts you find in
the world which is pretty cool and the
wasteland workshop one is coming in
april and that's five dollars that seems
to add just a bunch of stuff into
workshop designs you can capture raiders
and death clothes and sort of traps and
then a bunch of like additions to
various aspects of the creation stuff
and then the big one far harbor coming
at it sometime in may that's $25 it's a
sort of nick valentine quest off of that
where you basically travel off to
somewhere off the coast of maine there's
basically bar harbor is that right and
apparently so like probably a play on
that and yeah we travel off the coast of
maine to mysterious island were higher
levels of radiation have created a more
feral world and navigate through the
growing conflict between since the
children of adam and the local
townspeople we work towards bringing
peace to far harbor and what cost so
that's all coming out at the moment
these thirty dollars I guess season pass
still applies all that stuff adds up to
40 but actually the season pass because
they sort of went and there's more stuff
coming at after these packs but they've
also said that they're going to release
they're going to put the season pass up
to 50 bucks at the end of the month I
guess so a lot of stuff there 30 bucks
right now fifty bucks three of those
coming edge lots more coming up for the
rest of the year they also going to do
closed beta switch can opt into to get
all this stuff early if you want and
Peter you're a big fallout for a fan you
enjoy playing the game you reviewed the
game for gamespot com as well and what
do you think about this in terms of the
DLC strategy we've always known the be
dlc coming after this or assumed
does this stuff excite you know which of
the three sort of excites you the most
uh the bar harbor stuff sounds really
interesting to me because I definitely
found the stories that were a part of
the fallout 4 experience to be the most
interesting aspect by far that's what
kept me going and kept me like
interested in the moment-to-moment stuff
I didn't get anything out of the
workshop it didn't do right for me I
don't really care about that the robot
building aspect sounds kind of
interesting but I'm curious like how
deep that goes and to what extent that
actually like has an impact on the rest
of the game you're playing or if it's
some just like thing off to the side
yeah you know like here's a little robot
minigame type thing you can do Bethesda
a lot of fun I for had stuff off to the
side that never really impacted like the
settlements yeah I enjoyed doing that
stuff because for whatever reason just
OCD or just like tinkering with things
but it is like a very divisive part of
the game like tiny people didn't didn't
enjoy it did you do any of Suffolk uh I
did very little because definitely at
the time when we were you know giving
stuff up to do um was it not my priority
list I don't I guess I don't care about
that it's yeah it's a strange thing you
like to shooting more right I shooting a
looting baby see that the tone in his
voice got ya pep in your step but uh and
everyone in chat like yeah of course
Eric like salute game but yeah the
settlement stuff didn't really do
anything much for me the robot thing
like Peter said sounds cool sounds like
a kind of like a small little bite of
you know mission maybe like a couple
missions or something maybe just
something to do off to the side which it
sounds like the power armor a little
[ __ ] what they said here is choose from
hundreds of mods mixing limbs armor
abilities and weapons like the all-new
lightning chain gun even customize their
paint schemes and choose their voices so
that's cool so that sounds like a thing
where you can actually develop something
within the game that makes a difference
yeah generally like a like a what you
call them a partner like a companion
companion yeah basically yeah exactly
yeah but one that you can really just go
to town on I mean that's sounds good
yeah the workshop stuff seems pretty
small all right like I mean it's five
bucks so it's probably going to be
pretty small and then yeah the far
harbor based on Bar Harbor we're
assuming that's like that reminds me
very much of what they did which point
look at which was you get on a boat in
for a three you go off to like an
archipelago
and there's like this big calvert
mansion is there and all I cool stuff to
do around there and it's kind of
enclosed within the world and that stuff
always fun as well like when they just
let you go off somewhere and it's like
it maybe isn't necessarily affecting the
party's gonna be settlements in that
part as well you mentioned Nick
Valentine was that just sort of like a
reference not like an actual component I
think it's it says Valentine's detective
agency is where it starts so I think
maybe they got a call okay instead of it
just being like a radio signal pops up
like that's where the mission starts or
day it says it's the biggest landmass
they've ever put in expansion while
including including skyrim the elder
scrolls section so yeah stuff sounds
cool is redditing so they've said that
those are the first three I'm sure at e3
we're going to hear about what they're
doing for the rest of the year 30 bucks
seems pretty decent and considering what
you're getting and the chances of more
but is there anything that you guys
would like to see that they sort of
haven't touched on here anything that
you can think that they could add to the
game which is kind of a difficult
question because a lot of that stuff you
could say would be mods at this dance
kart racing car say horse racing like
The Witcher yeah i think if you know if
there's an opportunity to maybe expand
outside of boston which it sounds like
they're doing right i mean like that's
kind of all you can really do because
after you've played the game you've kind
of explored all boston that they've
already given you i had to be weird if
they tried to add more within that cuz
i'm gonna change the context of many
things yeah but yeah like more side
story stuff because there's obviously
you know this way it's like it took play
forget now it took place at the same
time as fallout 3 like the slightly
below study before I mean there's a lot
of times before there's stuff happening
the world around you outside of this
little city so just keep telling those
stories and do it with the same kind of
care with characters and society and
building those things and flushing them
out that's awesome so far um I don't
know I I mean I like that they're doing
more weapons and stuff like that i think
more fun stuff like that is always cool
i think it was funny watching rob do
like the the Jump Jet you just like oh
yeah bowling balls and floor he's like
yeah ever you might never touch as well
like the game is so expansive already so
maybe just one more fun guns and stuff
like that but like you said it's kind of
hard because those things are kind of
like almost like mods right they're
starting to get into that territory of
like
if it's not a story or mission or
something like that then just kinda like
yeah yeah it's a strange one to try and
plug in all this stuff into a game
especially if you've got like completed
a game like I find it strange going back
to the witcher a little bit and doing
more requests considering how my game
ended and they literally say this is
what happens to the main characters and
they like are just go back just chop
some [ __ ] that's all its range but
there there you go i guess last point
out is what do you guys think about the
price and forty dollars if you were to
buy it all separately i mean it's hard
to say without seeing what exactly the
stuff is 30 quid for a season pass ah
it's going up to 50 you're talking the
guy that buys destiny dlc so as long as
it uh you know and if it's the biggest
they've ever added you know it sounds
like you're gonna have a lot of you know
main mission type stuff with side story
stuff so sounds like it's a pretty good
deal I mean right if you want more
fallout I hate to equate like ours with
value right I spent 70 hours playing
fallout 4 and and I felt like I told you
know they provided us a copy of the game
but I got my theoretical money's worth
out of that $25 for an expansion however
big does seem a little bit pricey to me
I'd have to be really substantial and
something that I could spend a
significant amount of time with if I can
complete it in one like hefty sitting
nine four or five hours I would feel a
little bit strange about that yeah well
the reason the cost of the season pass
is very strange to me yeah it's it's
it's almost like they didn't expect that
they were gonna make as much stuff right
and if your baby doing that may be good
endo said a project way and give it for
free maybe a little bit like that the
workshop thing sounds a little bit like
you could have just gone there you go
yeah it's almost strange because I'm
like if if they do this right like I
don't know any other season pass that's
going up in price yeah down the road I
mean what's to stop that from becoming a
thing and then having people worry that
they need to purchase the season pass as
soon as possible let's do something like
this comes up I mean at least we're
getting a warning but it is a bit
strange yeah I think we've only got a
couple of weeks left so if you're
interested getting fallout 4 stuff go
get the season pass I guess or don't ya
figure it out maybe some of the the the
phone I three stock was very hot and
cold as well like you could not bother
with mothership zeta maybe some people
like that one like that was
kind of okay and saying was I guess was
operation anchorage as well which was
dubs canoes alright so maybe it's worth
seeing what the reviews are anyway let
us know what you think in the comments
below if you're interested in it if
you're going to pick up the season pass
if you're gonna pick up individually let
us know comments hello